hey everybody welcome back to the planet
goes through ski resort I know it's been
a while since the last video in this
series but I have to say it's January
I'm gonna be skiing in a few weeks so I
really got into the skiing mood and also
I'm a little bit bummed out of planets
too recently so what better to do than
to return to the ski resorts in Planet
go through and make sure that that
thing's not just hanging out there so
that's what we're doing today and
specifically I'm gonna be working on a
fun park or snow park or terrain park
whatever you want to call it I think
there are some national differences in
here doesn't matter too much
whatever the case a a fun park is
basically the ski resorts equivalent of
a skate park for those who don't know
too much about this kind of thing it's
an area with features such as jumps and
rails and boxes that people can do
tricks on and I have to say straight
away before I get into this then I'm not
really a great authority on this topic
because honestly I've always been too
much of a [ __ ] to actually do tricks on
these so all I've really done is maybe
some tiny jumps and I've put my skis on
some boxes and failed miserably so I'm
not even gonna try to pretend like I'm
an expert here but at the end of the day
they are a very common occurrence in ski
resorts especially nowadays in Europe
they've only started really catching on
in the last few years but it's something
that a good ski resort should always
have probably and they're just fun to
build as well so of course I wanted to
build one in planet coaster as well now
starting off with the elements I'm gonna
try to list these so pay attention to
what I'm talking about here and maybe we
can figure some stuff out so the first
element that I just built was a simple
jump honestly not too much to it with a
step down ramp specifically because
that's the thing which I think works
best with the in-game terraforming tool
a more common and easy type of ram.4
jumps is a simple tabletop where you go
up and then you have a flat section and
they go down but I think with the
terrain tool and planet coaster it's a
bit harder to make that look realistic
so I ended up going for a step down ramp
in
that and right here I'm working on a
rainbow box which is a simple box type
structure with a rainbow shape and you
could also call them a curved box or
whatever and these are honestly some of
the easier sort of elements and from one
of the few that I've ever put my skis on
top of something interesting is also
then apparently these things are made
out of polyethylene and it's just this
sort of plastic material that's made in
such a way that it's quite hard and you
can sort of jib on it as the pros would
call it but it doesn't hurt your skis or
snowboard and they have some rounded
edges as well so even though everything
looks quite edgy in in planet coaster
here in reality they they would have
just the right material to like not
damage your skis or your snowboard in
any way so here we have the rainbow box
and I just put down a flat down box
where you start off with a flat section
and then have this kink and afterwards
you go down so it's a very similar sort
of thing just you're following a
difference regex 3 pretty much and
another common occurrence beside these
so-called fun boxes is a rail which as
the name implies it's just a real
something some round tube of different
sizes and shape they don't even have to
be around sometimes you have some square
rules we'll get back into that later in
the video but yeah I decided to add one
of those as well a simple one which goes
from flat to down to flat as well and at
this point I decided to add a slightly
more intricate kind of rail which is a
bit strange I have to be honest this is
one that I didn't get from the booklets
for most of this video I was trying to
find online sources pictures and all
kinds of documents to see you know what
the exact features of a fun part
commonly are what their names are and
what they're made out of and for this
one I just sort of deviated from what I
saw usually if you have a reel and it
goes from flat down to flat
you just have two kinks one to go down
and want to go flat again and in this
one I figure
I kind of want to follow the shape of
the hill a bit more and just add to
kinks on top of it I don't know if I'm
destroying if I'm sort of
calling upon blasphemy of the fun part
community here but it's something that I
thought would look cool
so decided to go for this slightly less
standard shape here but it all works out
it's a slightly different real type as
well because it's a much thinner real
type with these plastic boards between
it so a little bit of variety in terms
of what the elements look like and what
the colors and materials are exactly as
well and finally to finish this section
of the fun park and decided to add
another ramp one mistake that I've sort
of made throughout this fun Park which
is kind of an unfortunate consequence of
the fact that this whole ski resort is
really quite small and I have to make
everything very cramped is that many of
the features are very close together
compared to an actual fun Park and the
ramp on the top section isn't well it's
too high up the hills and like actually
make a very good jump off of it I'm
afraid so I decided to add a jump at the
end of this whole fun Park section as
well so that if you really want to make
a big jump you can gather some speed and
finish off the fun Park section here so
again I'm trying to use the the paths to
my advantage here because it's very
difficult to shape out mountains with a
terraforming tool in such a way that you
have straight edges on the side because
at the end of the day these fun parks
get made every year just by shoving a
bunch of snow together into certain
shapes and putting the elements in it
it's something that doesn't stay in
summer it's always a temporary thing so
you have to make it look like this sort
of constructed winter fun park as
opposed to the very sort of permanent
setting of a skate park in a city and
yeah that is basically it for this
section of the park decided to just
finish it with a couple of poles beside
the jumps because that's something that
I saw some jumps in real life had as
well it's something that I haven't seen
in the ski resorts that I've been to
burn I figured yeah might as well
edit
so at this point I took a bit of a
sidestep
and decided to go back to this little
slope next to the chairlift and thought
I might as well add a bit more challenge
for some of the more professional skiers
or people who are just really good at it
or who love challenging themselves and
build a mogul slope also known as bumps
or also known in Germany as a book
called pista which I find strange
because the word mogul in English
apparently comes from the Bavarian and
Austrian word Mughal so the fact that
the English word is based on a German
word and the German word for this kind
of slope is different it's a bit
puzzling not sure what the linguistics
of that are but anyway it's a slope with
a bunch of bumps and as a skier it just
adds an extra challenge because you have
to be able to like make your curves
between or on top of these jumps
depending on ooh that was a pretty bad
voice crack depending on you know what
works out for you and especially as an
Olympic sport it's really hardcore
because it really takes a toll on your
knees it's quite heavy to do this kind
of thing especially when the slope is
very steep so it's always a fun
challenge and something that you see
very often in ski resorts just for
anymore expert skiers so it's something
that I wanted to add in this resort as
well now at this point I decided that
I've done enough stuff for anymore
expert skiers and snowboarders out there
and I should add something to cater to
the beginners as well so something that
I've wanted to do for a while but still
happens because it seemed like a very
daunting task is create a beginner slope
with a simple short surface lift and the
reason that I was so afraid of doing
this is well this surface lift I'm
building right here is made out of
pieces made by sea vism on the Steam
Workshop and again huge thanks go out to
them because this whole series wouldn't
have been possible without all the
amazing theme park toolkit items that
they uploaded the chairlift editions
that I added to the in-game chairlift
and gondolas come from them as well as
well as a bunch of other ski themed
hikers toolkit items like skis and
helmets and all kinds of things so
really without their help this whole
Cirie's wouldn't have happened and they
also made this whole sets to create a
surface lift including animated wheels
so this thing can actually function at
least it doesn't really function but it
looks like it could so that's super cool
and in real life surface lifts like this
are very common on beginner slopes
because they're very cheap they're very
easy to construct and they're also quite
old and I think the particular type of
surface lift that this one resembles
which is the Palmer lifts in real life
made by the manufacturer Poma
which has since fused into the lightener
Palmer which is one of the biggest
cableway manufacturers in the world
sorry going very off-topic here anyway
the Palmer lift is what this thing is
usually called in real life and because
it's so cheap and easy to build it's
something that you find on a lot of
beginner slopes kind of conversely
though it is something that beginners
often struggle with because unlike a
chairlift or a gondola you stay with
your feet on the ground in this kind of
lift so what happens in this lifts and
it's something I can't really visualize
in planet coaster here is that these
cables will have a bunch of sticks with
buttons at the end of them attached to
them and in the station you grab one of
these sticks with a button on it it just
passes by as the cable was moving and
you you put the button underneath your
buds and then it just drags you up the
hill so that's basically how it works so
you're still standing you're sort of
leaning onto the button but you're just
holding onto it and it ranks you up the
hill as the cable makes it go up so it's
not really the most comfortable thing so
it's sometimes quite a struggle for
beginners or kids to get used to them I
think as a kid I've fallen out of a lot
of sort of rope tow lifts like this
although for me personally the t-bar
lift is way worse that's a sort of like
two-person version of the same concept
it's I think the nightmare of a lot of
beginning skiers and something that a
lot of people end up falling out of
anyway they're often really short and
that's why they're used on beginner
slopes as well so you know you sometimes
you only need a 100 meter stretch of
slope to be so
a ski lift and it wouldn't really make
sense to build an entire gondola
chairlift for that then this lift works
out as well so that's something that
I'll return to later but I'm building it
in the location of a beginner slope and
I'm gonna be coming back to that later
as actually fledge fleshing out but I
thought realistically I've been doing so
much for the expert skiers in this
resort
I really should build something very
simple that beginners can go to as well
so basically that's the idea behind that
lift and once again thanks the C BISM
for creating that amazing tea makers
toolkit sense because without it I
really couldn't have built it now moving
back to the fun park at this part I
decided to add some fences partly
because I wanted to separate the
irregular slope if you will from the fun
park section and partly because there
are some jumps close to the forest here
and especially the one at the end is is
close to a curve where the forest sort
of looms in front of the the fun Park
section of this of this slope so I'm
gonna add some fences along that as well
just to make sure that people don't jump
straight into the trees because that
would kind of suck so they have a safety
feature as well by the way you might
have noticed up until this points that
the first part of this time-lapse was a
bit slower than usual this is partly due
to the fact that planet coaster was just
very slow and I constantly had to wait
very long to do place pieces but also I
just had to slow it down because things
were going a bit quicker than I could
explain them at first in the time-lapse
so yeah it's not quite the the twelve
times that I usually speed up my videos
maybe more like an 8 9 10 something like
that
not sure anyway maybe it makes a visual
difference maybe it doesn't just
something that I noted anyway moving on
to the second part of the fun park this
is a section that I wasn't really sure
if I was going to build it when I
started building this but at the end of
the day when I had finished the first
half I figured it wasn't really enough
it wasn't really feeling like a
full-fledged fun park and it just needed
a few more elements to finish it not to
mention that I have
very very wide section of slope here
with the perfect degree of slope I guess
to make a fun Pike out of it so
something I wanted to try here as well
now this part is interesting because I'm
building yet another reel but this one
is a square books reel and what you can
also see is that the sort of shape of a
rail so you'll have the rail itself and
then two sections on the sides where
your your skis or snowboard actually
make contact with the rail which I made
out of cable pieces in this case and
this one also kind of jumps off of this
this ramp that it has so you can also do
some tricks off of that and then here is
a simple ride on rain well I'm not
exactly sure what to call it actually
it's like a flat down flat box I would
call it a ride on as most of these
features are because there is a
difference between what some people call
a gap on feature or a ride on feature
when I ride on just connects to the
ground in front of it and you just
pretty much slide onto the feature and a
gap on is where you really have to jump
up to it and the only sort of gap on
that I can come up with is the first
rail that I made with the very thick
rail that sort of juts out of the snow
just behind the ramp which is a bit more
difficult of course to get on then just
a simple slide on but then again it's
also something that you can probably do
some tricks with as well and finally
well actually not finally I forgot one
feature there the second the last thing
that I built there was another rainbow
box but one that sort of flattens out
toward the end which is something that I
also haven't seen in real life but it
just seems like a pretty cool addition
to make it a bit more different and then
the actual final feature here is another
step down ramp very similar to the other
ones already just a little bit bigger
this one so I think you can probably do
the biggest jumps off of this ramp here
and this is also the final section of
the fun park and at this points the the
slope just returns so the section where
all the other slopes come together and
to this wide section where
you have the gondola to the side
actually fun facts at first I was always
planning to have the fun park right next
to the gondola there but then I realized
that this would probably create a bit of
a funnel effects because we do have
three different slopes coming together
at that point so realistically if this
resort was going to be quite busy I
wouldn't want the fun park to be in this
sort of narrow stretch of land where a
bunch of different slopes come together
so and I ended up opting for this one
because there's a lot more space here to
work with and yeah I think it just makes
more sense in that perspective I also
decided to add some useless space on the
side here which is not an actual slope
but just an empty area which clearly
demarcate the snow looks very different
there than it does on the actual slopes
which is something that's very difficult
to pull off in planet coaster in real
life it's something that you quickly
notice because the snow on the the non
slope sections is always a bit higher
and it's ungroomed so it looks bit messy
but in planet coaster it can be quite
difficult to make that difference in
texture very apparent but yeah that's
just a small touch to finish off this
section of the park and with that said
that's the end of this episode so I'd
like to thank you guys for watching and
I'll leave you with some cinematic
footage and I'll be back very soon with
another episode of this series so stay
tuned bye guys
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]